[Musique]
il n'y a jamais de problème
surtout pas quand il s'agit de se
demander ce qu'on va porter pour aller
dans une émission de télé grand public
diffusé à une heure de grande écoute
pourquoi pas une chemise avec des dames
dessus c'est des gens qui en serait nier
les gestes barrière en ce moment les
états unis souhaitent que l'on permette
la suspension des brevets qui protègent
les vaccins afin que tous les
laboratoires puisque les fabriques et ça
permet ça permettrait évidemment
d'accélérer considérablement à la
production mondiale et de répartir les
doses au sein de la population de la
planète c'est une annonce très forte et
c'est pourquoi le président américain
est notre homme du jour les nouvelles
idées de cadeaux pour inciter à la
vaccination où il a déjà parlé lorsque
les beignets aux états unis a aussi main
ce qu'ils proposent de la marijuana des
bons d'epargne en israël c'est de la
bière ou des pizzas et bien en inde on
innove dans la ville de rach cote ont
bon dos frein piercing nasale en or aux
amis se font vacciner et les hommes
reçoivent un mixeur voilà c'est bien
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par exemple
alors qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire et
bien
des mesures peut-être je ne sais pas
lors des mesures financières ça semble
un peu compliqué mais pourquoi pas après
tout se dire que on a une espèce de
petite allocation qui pourrait être
attribuée à chaque personne vaccinée
avec un schéma vaccinal complet au début
j'étais révoltée après j'étais
anesthésié et maintenant je suis
déprimée c'est tout vous enfoncez quand
même un peu et j'ai très peur qu'on en
sorte jamais en réalité aulas il ya
trois déconfinement successives mais
j'ai pas confiance je sens qu'il va y
avoir quelque chose qui va se passer
[Musique]
c'est là vous à l'époque ne jette pas le
masque est tout de suite et puis on
continue à respecter les gestes barrière
j'ai l'impression que ce virus il est
personnellement dirigé contre moi parce
que c'est tout ce que j'aime c'est aller
au cinéma ensuite aller au restaurant
avec des copains d'hier est normal du
film est ensuite allé boire de la vodka
dans une discothèque
donc là on a supprimé toute ma vie ma
passion c'est un plat qui se mange sens
où ce bon vous était très inquiet pour
les ratures et et copernic up bon vous
nous avez apporté un gland alors on
l'appelle sa non pas un gland mais
plutôt une bonbonnière de notre côté
donc voila tout à fait alors c'est ceci
dit c'est très joli et très beau autres
c'est l'une des publications les plus
populaires du moment sur instagram et
will smith assume son embonpoint et
confie être dans la pire forme de sa vie
il n'est pas le seul au vu du nombre
d'hommes qui diffuse à leur tour des
photos d'eux et de leur ventre
pendant la pandémie l'acteur de 52 ans
avoue s'être laissé aller
mais c'est fini will smith annonce qu'il
va lancer une série sur youtube
consacrée à sa remise en forme
abu garçon comme ça avant avant de
goûter le gâteau j'ai envie de voter
on parle évidemment si vous voulez bien
par l'abattement mais vous savez
quelquefois petit coup de canif dans le
contrat
c'est vrai que je n'aime pas la majorité
pardon le nombre de fois qu'il a trompé
quand une fois à cette fois waouh
d'accord les biens mis l'ambiance
je peux dire que voilà et la bonne
journée sinon l'information assez
étonnante c'est vrai que quand une maman
tu donne naissance à un enfant la
féliciter bien là il va falloir félicité
neuf fois une jeune maman malienne vous
avez bien entendu halim al himma cissé a
donné naissance par césarienne à cinq
petites filles et quatre petits garçons
au maroc
trois gynécologues ciré animateurs dont
3 spécialisé en néonatalogie et un
radiologue sont mobilisés pour extraire
sept bébés
on a fait sortir de sa torpeur en
rigolant je me dis on va chercher le
placenta et j'ai trouvé encore de grève
équipé la gt2 les deux petits 500 g 520
parce que les autres canaux où ils sont
900 mille grains aussi incroyable que
cela puisse paraître deux bébés tout
petit et est resté invisible à
l'échographie hip hop hip hop type mois
mordre familièrement dans le sud mais
l'attaqué du mois 10 20 hockey non la
vie à bord on y accueille alors j'étais
[ __ ] et moi je viens du sud un regard
là c'est passé de me mentir
c'est vraiment dur de parler de dire les
choses se trouve si je devais l'agresser
trop face au moi je te dis la vérité la
malemort j'ai pas envie de me prendre un
mur
je préfère prendre mes distances jeudi
la note
donc là qu'on perd son bras qu au bout
d'un moment je suis pas dans dont la
force soit les abattoirs il faut les
changer
la vidéo dans les abattoirs gros ce qui
s'y passe
le débat brûlant guère voix puissante i
need a roulé un peu de travers ne tuons
pas les engagements non la b vers labège
à une rapide du labrum dans vous dit
lundi vers quoi c'est pas la peine non
là non
c'est ça elle devient totalement
ingérable les policiers doivent employer
la force pour l'emmener au poste merci
seul accroc in montant détruit le seul
combat contre bon bah je suis trop et je
suis comme ça merci solveig d'abord est
avec nous